das ist das Fragenlotto okay mit netten
und harmlosen Fragen wir jA greif
einfach mal rein wir nennen sie die
harmlose und die frchtlose das ist ein
harmlos ganz grün ist harmlos meinst du
die grün ist harmlos grün ist ganz
harmlos in dem Fall ja was unterscheidet
dich von anderen DSDS Gewinnern
ja schwierig das von sich zu sagen keine
Ahnung also ich ich habe mir meine Ziele
gesteckt
und ich weiß wo was ich möchte
und natürlich nimmt man sich
auch vieles an aber das muss man
erstmal für sich auch verarbeiten
und zusehen dass dass man halt sich
nicht durch viele Sachen verbiegen lässt
einfach oder sich in ander W lenken
lässt die man überhaupt nicht machen
möchte du hast richtig gemacht du bist
Rocker hast dadurch ein konzertpuikum
und du hast ja eine starke Fangemeinde
erhalten das ist ja glaube ich so das A
und O bei
DSDS ja das ist ja also mir war von
vornean wichtig und ich habe natürlich
die Chance ergriffen dass ich Hal sehr
viel live spielen kann jetzt und
natürlich die richtige Agentur habe die
unsere Konzerte einfach buchen oder
verbuchen irgendwo
und ja das ist das Wichtigste eigentlich
weil nur dann das das reicht ja
meinesachens nicht wenn wenn wenn ich
jetzt nur irgendwie ein CD oder ein
Album kaufe oder irgendwie eine Single
und nicht auf de Konzert von von von
einem Künstler oder gehen kann halt so
ne ich möchte das auch gerne live
erleben und deshalb ist da mein ja mein
anspor da drin so und für uns als als
Band einfach ganz viel live zu spielen
und Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten dass
man auch eventuell auch nur ganz neue
Leute damit erreicht konzertgender halt
g ein furchtlos vielleicht zur
Abwechslung du hast nicht beim zweiten
Album Richtung g auch stärker in die
Entstehung des Songs eingeklingt kannst
du überhaupt komponieren also ich hab
Melodien im Kopf
die ja ich für mich selbst halt und die
gebe ich dann halt an Gitaristen weiter
an Leute die Instrument sehr gut
beherrschen oder halt am Klavier die
Melodie nachspielen und so entstehen
halt auch Songs also du kannst
komponieren aber nicht am Instrument
nicht am Instrument aber im Kopf so also
meine meine Gesangslinien Halt und wo
kommt das bei unter der Dusche beim
Autofahren ja verschieden auch beim also
eigentlich überall dann su ich da mein
Liedchen irgendwie oder ME me me meine
Melodie dain rum und die baue ich dann
halt aus und dann also ich versuche
natürlich mit einem mit sogenannten Ref
oder so so so so eine Hook Melodie zu
entwickeln und dann gucke ich wie man
wie man auf die Melodie halt auch mal
eine melodiestofhe stropenmelodie auch
machen kann oder was passt denn dazu
aber muss der ist auch im Kopf behalten
oder hast du das muss behalten oder man
man man
mitm Handy aufnehmen oder so also ein
Aufnahmegerät weil das vergisst man ja
auch immer recht schnell und das
versuche ich dann halt mit deem
Aufnahmegerät festzuhalten und dann gehe
ich zum zum zum Rene oder zum SEB und
sag hier kannst du mal kurz nachspielen
so funktioniert das sag kein Problem ja
ja sucht er sich die Akkorde daraus und
mach das du kannst auch blind greifen
wie du möchtest du kannst
auch
ein
harmlos grün ist harmlos also immer
harmlos immer ganz lieb warum hast du so
eine starke Fancommunity weil das die
geilsten Leute der Welt sind auf jeden
Fall
alles richtig das Management zu wechseln
oh
ja ja ich sag mal wenn wenn wenn die
Meinung halt von einem Berater oder
einer Person die man eigentlich
vertrauen soll
auseinandergehen verschiedene Meinungs
also wenn man Meinungsverschiedenheit
und verschiedene Ansichten hat oder
Ansichten zu zu irgendwelchen Sachen und
das funktioniert die Chemie stimm nicht
oder
dann dann muss man sich einfach davon
trennen weil dann sieht man da halt
einfach keine Zukunft drin und
beim ersten Management war es einfach
nicht nicht die Philosophie die ich da
ja fahren wollte deshal habe ich mich
getrennt kann man sich auch trennen
sindt ja nicht so Verträge die x
Klauseln drin haben D überhaupt und
natürlich schwierig gewesen dann war das
gegenseitigen Einverständnis ich habe
natürlich auch ein Gespräch gesucht und
habe halt gesagt pass auf das
funktioniert so nicht und
ich möchte mich gerne jetzt hier lösen
und das hat natürlich hat das alles über
funktioniert das über Anwälte und
muss da muss man sich einig werden und
ja das ist meistens immer eine
finanzielle halt Kiste aber das
überlasse ich auch immer meinem Anwalt
gut
was entspannendes jede Frage B doch
alles
super was bedeutet deine Karriere für
dich natürlich fühle ich mich in dem in
der Rolle sehr wohl und ich bin
natürlich kann immer wieder nur betonen
dass ich die letzten Jahre hart dafür
gekämpft habe oder
wir dals als Band einfach
viel dafür gegeben haben und
ich habe immer daran irgendwie
festgehalten geglaubt dass es doch
irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gibt ja alles
ein bisschen ein bisschen
professioneller aufzuziehen und aus dem
Hobby auch Beruf zu machen ich meine das
das haben viele natürlich diesen Wunsch
und man muss einfach daran glauben
festhalten und dann sein Ziel
verfolgen das habe ich versucht und das
natürlich auch Wege irgendwie sich
andere Kanäle suchen wo wo es möglich
ist und
ja es ist Gott sei Dank Hal zugekommen
jetzt h du doch Gott sei Dank Gott sei
Dank ja
ja ja man sagt das ja so man sagt das so
aber man sagt es so man sagt es so ja
wie soll ich das denn sonst
ausdrücken Dank meinerau Fähigkeiten
natürlich du hast eine riesige
Fangemeinde würdest du da nicht mal
Größen
wahnsinnig oder würdest du nicht
manchmal wirst du da nicht wirst du da
nicht manchmal grüßen wahsinnig oh
Gott
ne nee alles ist alles ist
so wie es ist finde ich das in Ordnung
und ich hör mir alles an ich gehe zu den
Leuten versuche einfach mit den halt
auch ein Gespräch zu führen und das ist
ja ganz
wichtig gut s jetzt alle machen wir
können gerne wir müssen aber nicht alle
machen
kannag bin es satt doofen Fragen guck
mal nur diese ganz gefährlichen Fragen
hier hat ich der Erfolg
nee also
ich ich sehe das alles mit einem
gesunden Menschenverstand und ich weiß
dass das morgen auch natürlich auch
alles vorbei sein kann
und diese diese 10 Jahre Erfahrung die
man halt so in dem in dem Geschäft oder
Musik gemacht hat so die haben die
bringen mer wieder auf bodende Tatsachen
Bodenhaftung Bodenhaftung ja und es kann
auch natürlich alles anders aussehen von
daher und für verbiegen lassen habe ich
mich auch nicht also ich habe immer mein
me mein meine Sache verfolgt und
ja
gut die letzten beiden noch wir geben
uns immer so viel
Mühe handiert diese
Fragen wie war dann letztes Jahr
wunderbar
okay jetzt noch ein saurer Drop zum
Schluss Drops
Drops hast du Angst zurück in die
Bedeutungslosigkeit zu
fallen ich komme aus der
Bedeutungslosigkeit und ich fürchte mich
nicht ich kämpfe auch mit dem Teufel vor
mir aus okay nein ähm
nee
also wie gesagt also man muss das alles
immer sehr realistisch sehen
und es wird wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo
mal wieder Berg abgehen aber irgendwo
mal ist auch ne also wenn man wenn man
in so so so ein Meer mit seinem Boot
irgendwo
hinfährt auf die auf die auf die See
fährt und irgendwo mal ist auch wieder
Land in Sicht
irgendwo von
daher und man muss natürlich weiterhin
sich immer sehr viel Mühe geben also
also das ist ja auch Arbeit und ich sag
mal wenn wenn wenn du dein Job nicht
nicht vernünftig machst dann kicken sie
dich auch irgendwann mal so von daher
und dann suchst du dir vielleicht noch
was anderes oder wo du halt besser
aufgehen kannst so vergleiche ich das
einfach dann drücke ich dir und uns die
Daum nicht passiert alles klar vielen
dank vielen Dank für das Interview ja
gerne super